- Associate, business analyst,
consultant, partner, director,
manager, engagement manager, principal,
what do all these terms mean?
In today's video, I'm
going to explain to you
how a career in consulting looks like,
how it works and what you can expect
if you decide to join one of
these large consulting firms
like McKinsey, BCG or Bain.
Today, I'm going to talk about,
what the key career steps
in the life of an MBB
consultant looks like,
what you actually can expect.
And I trust that if you watch
this video until the very end,
this can really help you to understand
whether a career in an MBB consulting firm
is the right thing for you to do or not.
Welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
And on Firm Learning,
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
My name is Heinrich,
I'm a former McKinsey consultant myself.
I spent about six years with the firm
and in this video I really
wanna share some insights.
How you can expect your
consulting career to evolve.
Let's start by demystifying
all these different
roles that are out there.
So if you browse any career page
of a large consulting firm,
you will indeed see all these terms
that I mentioned in the beginning.
So let's break it down.
And to make it easy,
there are pretty much
only three relevant roles in consulting.
There's the associate role,
the project lead role
and the partner role.
In this video, I will go over
each of these roles in detail
and explain to you exactly
what they are all about.
But now to clear out all this confusion,
let's just give you some synonymous terms
that are often frequently used.
So depending on the firm, you look like,
the associate can also be called
business analyst, consultant,
junior or senior associate,
associate consultant,
or any other combination of these terms.
What makes it even more confusing
is not only that these terms
of course, change firm by firm,
but even within the firms
there might be differences
among the different offices.
For instance at McKinsey, in many offices
there is a business analyst role, a BA,
but in Germany this does doesn't exist.
The German equivalent is called a fellow,
which again doesn't exist
in most other countries.
So you can see it's quite complicated
but don't get confused
it's much easier than you might think.
Next is the project lead.
And some equivalents here
are engagement manager,
case team lead, manager or project lead,
and indeed any other variation of that.
Again, don't get confused,
the project leader is the guy responsible
for the project on the ground.
The third role is the partner role.
Here some equivalents are principal,
director, senior partner,
junior partner, social principal
and again other variations.
And with all of these roles,
these are often then also
formulated in a hierarchy, right.
So maybe first you become
an associate principal,
then you become a principal
then you become a partner
or a senior partner.
So of course these are order
but again the exact terms differ by firm.
So let's start with the first
role of these three roles,
and this is the associate role.
The associate role is the first role
that you will jump in when
you start in consulting.
It is the role that you will
have as a young graduate.
And even most experienced hires
will join the MBB firms
in an associate role
but of course, in a bit more
senior level within this role.
Associates are the ladies and gents
that really get their hands dirty, right?
These are the ones that will conduct
most of the data analysis,
these are the guys that
will really work in Excel
to build these models,
crunch the client data,
these are the people that create
most of the PowerPoint pages.
And of course, these are the people
that sit together with clients
pretty much all day
having conversations with them,
conducting interviews with them,
collecting information that
then they try to consolidate
and synthesize for their project.
In MBB firms or McKinsey, BCG or Bain,
you can trust that even
if you're super junior
as a consultant, usually
even as an intern,
you will not just be an assistant,
but you will always
from the very beginning,
be responsible for a
distinct part of the project.
So there are different names
for that consulting
firm by consulting firm.
Some call it a module,
other a project part,
other a work-stream,
but often you try to cut,
in the beginning of the project
into different sub elements.
And if you wanna understand this process
of structuring a project even better,
check out my video on
hypothesis-based problem solving,
I will link it somewhere above here.
Then I will cut the project into pieces,
and then often you will be responsible
for one of these pieces.
And now the more experience
you have in the associate role,
the higher your ranks are
within these associate roles.
Often you will be responsible for larger,
more complex, more complicated modules.
Whereas you as a young BA
might start with a smaller task,
maybe you will be responsible
for a financial model that
the team needs to work on.
So this is the associate role,
it doesn't matter whether you are a BA,
an associate or consultant,
whatever it's called,
this is what you will do
in such an MBB project.
The second of the three roles
is the project lead role.
So typically after two to five years
working in an associate role.
How long exactly it takes
depends on what your
level is when you start.
So if you start just with a bachelor,
it will take longer than
if you start as an experienced hire
already with an MBA or PhD.
But after two to five years,
you will usually transition
into the project lead role.
And the main transition here
is that as a project lead,
you're not only responsible
for a small module of work
stream of the overall project,
but you are responsible
for the project as a whole.
And together with that,
of course you will be responsible
for the whole project team
that works on that project.
A typical team size for an MBB project
is a team of two to five consultants.
So as the project lead,
you will usually work together
with one to four other associates
that you will lead, you will guide.
So as a young project lead,
this would be the first
transition that you make.
Now, you are responsible for your team.
You need to teach them,
you need to coach them.
And of course, this can put
you also in a lot of stress
because now you need to
both manage upwards and manage downwards.
Now you are the direct
contact person for the partner
who will teach you to get more done
in a short amount of time.
But at the same time,
you are also the contact
person for your associates
Who pretty much will go to you
if they believe their lifestyle
is not getting good enough anymore.
They will ask you to reprioritize the work
and make sure they don't work too late.
And of course you might also be confronted
with a whole new set of
people leadership skills.
So what do you do if you realize
that maybe one of the
associates on the team
is not performing to the level
that you would want them to perform?
How do you handle that?
How do you conduct the feedback?
How do you try to head them?
At what point do you need
to escalate the situation?
So all of these are new
challenges that you're facing
that you did not face as an associate.
And on top of that especially in teams
where you only have one or two associates
on smaller teams, often the project lead
also will need to take care of
at least one smaller
works through for himself.
So besides all these
leadership activities,
often, there's also at least one piece
of very operational work
that you still need to do
and need to complete as well
just like all the other associates.
So you might end up with
lots of things on your plate,
but in the end this is indeed
what you need to get
done as a project lead.
This is what you are responsible for.
Now to the third of the three roles.
And this is the partner role.
So typically after two to
three years as a project lead,
you will advance into
the partner position.
What's important here to understand
is that most firms have a level
between project lead and partner.
You pretty much already
do the partner role,
but you're technically
not an elected partner
of the firm yet.
The main difference from the partner role
to the project lead role,
is that now in the partner role
for the first time,
you're responsible for different projects
at the same time.
While the project lead
only works on one project,
the partner now needs to take care of
different projects in parallel.
Depending on your seniority as a partner
and how many projects
you have in parallel,
the partner typically
is on the ground with the team
one or two times per week,
or up to one or two times per month,
if you are a super senior director,
senior partner of the firm
that you are working for.
As a partner, you are
the main contact person
for the board member for the senior client
who actually sponsored the project.
In the end, the partners are the people
that pitch their projects to these people.
So they are then also responsible
for the project success in the very end.
This also means that as a partner,
significant share of your time
will be dedicated towards
creating these pitch documents,
thinking about how you could create value
with new projects for your clients,
and then going out
conducting the pitchers,
wining and dining with
these senior clients
to make sure that your business
as a partner is growing.
Towards the teams,
you will help them
with overarching guidance on the projects.
In your portfolio of projects
that are going on at the same time,
you will often have certain projects
where the team at the moment
is struggling for whatever reason.
You will have certain projects
or maybe the client at the
moment is not satisfied.
So these will then be the projects,
or maybe you need to
invest a bit more time
to make sure that the
team gets back on track
to make sure that the demands
of the clients are met.
Of course assuming that
these demands are feasible.
So this is really how
the career looks like.
You start off in the first
role, in the associate role.
As an associate, your responsibilities
will increase over time
then at some point,
you transition to the project lead
by being responsible for the whole project
for your teammates,
the other associates on the ground.
And then after that,
suddenly you're responsible
for a whole set of projects
and you are now the
person towards the client
who then reaches out to them, pitches them
and then is being asked to
conduct new projects for them.
So I hope that this now demystifies
the career of the consultant,
and I hope that this
helps you to understand
whether this might be a career path
that you might be interested in as well.
If you have any questions
as always leave me a comment
below in the comment section.
And I will not only try to give
my very best to answer you,
but with every comment
you are also very much helping me
in supporting the channel
because comments and engagement
always look great to the YouTube systems.
So if you took any value
out of this video at all
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
And of course also subscribe
to stay up to date on all my content.
If you want to see even more from me,
follow me on my Instagram
my handle is firmlearning.
I have a mailing list,
you can sign up to that below
in the video description
And I recently also started
to become more active on LinkedIn.
My LinkedIn is also below
in the video description,
feel free to reach out
and follow me to stay in contact with me
on LinkedIn as well.
And now I want to say,
thank you to all the
members of Firm Learning.
This really means a lot to me.
You're really supporting the cause.
And if you want to
become a member as well,
hit the join button next
to the subscribe button
and you will get access
to some nice member only perks
that you will have advantage of.
So thank you so much for
watching until the end.
This really means a lot to me.
I release videos every single Saturday.
So stay tuned until next week,
this is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Bye-bye.